there is a comedian her name is I
believe Dina Araz know so she makes a
joke on Comedy Central's night at the
Comedy Cellar about the rapper xxx tent
a/c on she's had some [ __ ] man yeah he's
very beloved within the hip-hop
community but he's also very
controversial because he was known in
the past you have had like there were
allegations never confirmed of him
beating his pregnant girlfriend at the
time and abusing other women but I'll
try to be funny here is he the one who
passed away yes he is the one don't know
what had done yes okay he died because
he went to go buy a car he had $50,000
on him the people who murdered here in
Miami yes in Myakka Ferrari or something
yeah it's just a young guy who wanted to
go get a car had a lot of cash on him
robbed got robbed and he died so this
comic made on economy central right
mm-hmm cuz I saw so many comics tweeted
out about it and I didn't understand
what they're talking about
so this is the joke and I guess people
were like Comedy Central how do you how
do you not back up this comic you know
like you know comedy should have no
limits well how do you not back her up
in County Central to come out go we
didn't pull the thing she pulled it
she's getting death threats yeah tell me
stems were going we didn't do anything
soap let me see what's going on here do
you have all the low energy in the world
what's going on there babe I'm doing
some coffee wake up bro listening how
are asleep I was just listening go he's
a he's a rapper who was murdered he's
dead down um he was he was shot he was
on his way to buy a car with $50,000 in
cash and somebody shot him and took the
money which is very tragic I think also
it would be a very good venmo commercial
that's good joke it's not a bad joke
that's the first thing I thought that's
how problems good comments that's it oh
he has a very large fan base a lot of
people really loved him and that's why I
get so much these are people just trying
to put know a community and hold on
other comics went after Oh some other
comic went after and people just [ __ ]
they find out real comics um that's what
it yeah if there were the comics they're
not they're not there's no that's a good
joke
sorry that's hilarious joke but
unfortunately she is getting death
threats she ended up um pulling that
joke and she says that she's ever gonna
say it what's her name like Gina Gershon
there's stay strong and [ __ ] all these
dummies that was a good joke and you're
a good comic most most be mean most
people had everyone's most comments are
defended
yeah it is a good video [ __ ] Advent
mouth yeah I mean she's not saying it's
very tragic and it is and of course
again this this [ __ ] culture look at
this so patch that cancel commie central
Deena Hoffman who are thinking XX
whatever the [ __ ] his name is being
robbed and murdered is funny oh my god
you guys you guys are such Oh let's do
that then let's [ __ ] do it
[ __ ] shoutout he's just got Dave he's
got young fans who are heartbroken that
he died and I get it and they're they're
in a group and they get to gang up and
it put brings you together
he will make fun of abortion 9/11 Hitler
cancer AIDS racism and everything else
under the Sun but X is where the line is
drawn its stand-up comedy all subjects
are fair game correct then this little
point but X was a huge inspiration to a
whole generation he made a huge impact
who's trying to change the world and
touch so many people that's why alright
okay dude you're young and extreme and
it's fine alright next one that's so
interesting I saw so many comics reach
out but I didn't know what's going on
funny game hash am I like this right now
yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your tongue oh
good what's gonna happen what are you
gonna do use some of that boxing you've
been doing
[ __ ]